[MUSIC PLAYING]
EARL J. WAGNER: We'll be talking
about a recent innovation
of an action course online.
And so just to give a little
bit of background for you,
Thom, that you had
worked as an engineer
in environmental engineering
and had worked in the '80s,
bringing your crew
there, doing trainings
for Fortune 500 companies.
And then, I guess it
was about early 2000s,
you discovered the
Approach the Practices
promoted by Marshall Rosenberg.
So nonviolent communication.
And it led to a big shift in
your career and your work.
So maybe we can start there.
THOM BOND: Yeah, it was right
around the turn of the century.
I read a book called
"Non-Violent Communication--
A Language of Life."
By the time I finished reading
chapter 1, it kind of hit me.
I'd found what I
was looking for.
And what I was looking
for was like a skill set,
a set of concepts,
ideas, that we
could use to actually get
along better, frankly,
just to be able to
move through conflict.
And I'd been looking
for a long time
and hadn't found anything
that really resonated with me.
And then I read this book, and
kind of the rest was history.
When I read the
book, I was involved
in actually alternative energy.
And we were applying--
I had an energy
services company.
And we would apply technology
to buildings, basically.
And so when I saw this,
actually I sold my company,
because I thought this was
really exciting that I could
apply this new
technology that we call
nonviolent communication
or it's also called
compassionate communication.
So I was really excited about
using this new technology,
which is obviously
more human-oriented
as opposed to building-oriented.
EARL J. WAGNER: Sure,
so kind of seeing
some of the same approaches
in terms of thinking
of engineering in
terms of buildings
or like creating
artifacts in the world,
and then actually noticing
some of the connections
or noticing some of the
patterns or approaches
that you were discovering
with and we see.
Is that right?
THOM BOND: Yeah.
It was very specific.
And really what
Marshall Rosenberg,
the guy who wrote that
book, had discovered it
over a 30 year period.
He had been studying
what connects people
and what disconnects people.
And so he had really
just kind of sussed
out that when we can
pay attention to,
what we can bring our focus to
our needs, which are universal,
our universal human needs,
that when we do that,
we're way more likely to be
able to understand one another.
EARL J. WAGNER: That's
helpful to actually get
to the core of this approach.
And so we do actually
have some needs over here.
And maybe you can
share more about
what's that all about for people
who aren't familiar with this.
THOM BOND: Well
one of the things
we do is we define
needs very specifically.
And it's not like I need a
car or I need a house or a I
need a spouse.
It's really, what is it
that motivates us to do--
actually you could look at
this as what motivates us
to do every single thing we do.
In other words, we can
look at all human behavior
from a perspective of need.
And in other words
no matter what
you're doing, whether
it's scratching your head
or bombing a building,
the idea is that we're
in pursuit of our needs.
We're trying to
fulfill our needs.
And what's so
important about that is
that it is universally human.
It's not cultural.
Needs are not cultural.
We are born with them.
And so as you can see, we look
at these words, none of these
are the ways we meet needs.
They're actually the
needs themselves.
And so when we start
looking at our behavior
from this perspective,
I can relate to you
no matter what you've done,
because we have the same needs.
So it created a
common ground for us
to be able to begin the
process of conflict resolution.
EARL J. WAGNER: And
so going back to kind
of your own history,
that's something
that you found so
transformative.
You mentioned having your
alternative energy business,
selling that, and
really diving in--
can you speak to you, were
there any stories or any times
that really sort
of opened your eyes
and really kind of
gave you this clarity?
THOM BOND: Well yes.
I mean in particular--
well first I'd like to
say, this technology
operates wherever
there are humans.
So all of the different levels
of relationship that we have,
this applies to, whether
we're nation to nation,
tribe to tribe,
person in person.
And so my first
experience of this
that was really moving for
me was actually my father--
we have a long history--
who is also an engineer.
And we have this long history of
conversing in such a way that--
well, you know, it would be
like, "Thom, how's it going?",
my father would say.
And I would say,
"Well, we're fine.
We're doing this.
We're doing that."
And in particular we
had just started NYCNVC
and I had this
conversation with him where
he said, "How's it going?"
I said, "Well,
it's going great."
It's true, we had
a lot of activity.
People were getting interested.
And so he came back, as
he would normally do,
and he'd say, "Well
Tom, that's great.
But do you have
a business plan?"
And so I was like, "Yes, we
do have a business plan."
And he was like, "Oh, that's
great, because you know,
you've got to have
a business plan.
Is it in writing?"
So we had had this conversation
for decades, literally decades.
So I would tell him
what I was doing.
He would tell me what
I was doing wrong.
And so this went on.
So I was like, "Yes, we
have a business plan.
And it's in writing."
He says, "Well that's good.
Does your business plan
have a Gantt chart?
Because it's got to
have a Gantt chart."
And so I was just swimming
in this old conversation
that we'd had over and
over and over again.
And at one point I was
eyeing the exits of the room.
So the conversation continued.
And finally he said,
"Well Tom, it's great
that you have a business plan.
It's great that you've
got a Gantt chart.
But none of that matters.
None of that matters
because you really
have to get your act together.
You know, you really
can't just talk about this
or even just write about it.
You have to get out
there and do it."
And so I was [GROANS].
Really I was just so tense.
And then I remembered
this phrase
that we have in
nonviolent communication
which is everything we
do, we do to meet a need.
And so somehow that got
into my head, luckily.
And I was thinking,
OK, everything we do,
we do to meet a need.
What need could he possibly
be trying to meet here
by beating me up like this?
And it was an amazing
moment in my life
because I actually thought
about it for a minute.
And then it hit me.
I was like, "Dad, so
is it that you'd really
like me to do well
out there and you'd
love it if I benefited
from your experience?"
So I'm thinking, what
is he trying to do here?
And so I asked him that.
Just want me to benefit
from your experience.
And he was like, yes.
And it was just an
amazing moment for me,
because what happened,
from my perspective,
from my experience,
was he went from being
this kind of
didactic know it all
to this other guy who
just simply wanted
to contribute to me.
And I have children,
so I get that.
I understand, we all want to
contribute to our children.
And this was how he knew how.
He was a world renowned
troubleshooter.
And so he was
troubleshooting me.
And although on the
outside, at first glance
it felt terrible, for the first
40 years it felt pretty wicked.
But then from that moment
on, I had a perspective
that allowed me to
see him differently.
It was what I call a
transformative moment,
because it was an
instantaneous change for me.
And the thing that
I noticed about it
was that he didn't
have to change.
I mean, he's still
who he is and he still
talks to me in the same way.
The thing is I get to
hear him different.
And so what's the difference?
Well, I hear him for his needs.
And when that happens,
you can have that shift.
And right after
that I was hooked.
It's like, this, I
have to do more of.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah, it
sounds really powerful,
that what had been such
a struggle for you,
like the troubleshooting,
and for you
being able to actually
look underneath
to see this kind of
fundamental humanity
that was connecting both of
you, in terms of his needs.
That's something that
you noticed early on.
And that kind of fed you,
give momentum to the work
that you're doing.
Can you share more about--
we'll kind of continue on.
So you were building up NYCNVC.
It was more of a focus
on in-person trainings.
Can you share more about--
THOM BOND: Well that's kind of
all there was, back in the day.
So we did a lot in the
room kind of training
for small groups and your
typical workshop environment.
So that's where I really
got my education originally.
And so I guess over time--
and we do also, at NYCNVC,
we do live workshops.
I think that's still
an important aspect.
The thing is, live
workshops are expensive.
And you can only fit so
many people in a room.
I was frustrated
because I just find
this to be such an
incredible body of knowledge
that I wanted to
do what I could,
just constantly trying to figure
out ways that we could get
more of this out there further.
That's when we came
up with this idea,
or I came up with the idea of
the compassion course, which
is an online course.
And it's relatively simple.
In a way, I mean,
it just started out
as emails sent out
on a regular basis.
And around that we
created a community.
And we did that
with online forum.
We did it with a Facebook page.
And so we were able to
get everybody out there,
like eventually now
with thousands of people
out there, doing
it individually.
But yet each one of those people
is affecting their environment.
So it worked.
The format that we
chose was pretty simple.
It was just, here's a concept.
And then here is a story
that illustrates that.
And the third portion would
be, here are exercises that I
can do to integrate that.
So one is, I got
to see what it was.
And stories are kind of-- we're
very geared toward learning
through stories.
And the feedback that
I got was, I just
can't wait to get to the story.
And the thing that
I like about that
is, particularly
nonviolent communication,
we are introducing
unusual concepts,
things that are not going
to stick in your mind
very readily.
And so the idea of story
was, well, wait a minute,
I can remember a story.
So what we did was we started
embedding the concepts
in stories.
And then that would allow people
to have better integration.
EARL J. WAGNER: Noticing how
the way that you presented it
evolved as you were kind of
going through year by year.
And just to give
some of the context,
so the format is a
year long course.
It begins in the
summer, begins in--
THOM BOND: The first
Wednesday in the summer,
or the winter if
you're in Australia.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah.
And everyone is actually taking
it in a synchronized way.
THOM BOND: Yeah.
And I like that idea as opposed
to a book, where a lot of folks
buy a book and then it
sits there on your table
and you'll read it
every now and again.
This had more of a--
because of the
community aspect--
and it's funny, I wrote
it the way I like to read,
which is nice little
bedtime stories,
like three, four page chapters.
So it's 52 of these
little chapters.
And it caught on.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah, how did
you-- maybe how did you know--
what were the first indicators
that it was actually
starting to take off?
THOM BOND: Well the
first year I did it,
we decided we were not going
to charge any money at all,
because I don't expect people
to pay for something that they
don't know what it is, right?
So the first year we decided
to just put it out there.
And we got 550 folks.
And I actually hadn't
even written it yet.
So a lot of what
it was to me also
was what they call
in Ireland throwing
your hat over the wall.
I said, by the world, we are
having this amazing course.
And so I had to create it.
So I had some kind
of selfish motives
there too to do it in that form.
EARL J. WAGNER:
[INAUDIBLE] start
where we talk about actually
validating the idea,
putting it out there,
putting the idea out there,
seeing if actually
it grabs people.
THOM BOND: And it did.
550 people is a lot more--
I mean, the most I'd
ever had in a workshop
was maybe 60 or 70 people.
So the idea of being
able to reach 550 people
was pretty exciting.
So we really didn't
know how it was
going to grow or not grow from
there until the second year.
And the second year
we monetized, kind of.
And the idea was,
we picked $1 a week.
It was kind of a random
thing, but we thought, $52.
And then we gave
people the option
of taking a 50% scholarship
or a 100% scholarship, or pay
double.
And it was an
experiment, really.
And it turned out that
our average registration
was coming-- dollars per
registration ended up
being kind of feasible,
which was like in the $20s.
And what I loved
about that was it
was really working in terms
of getting it out there.
But yet it was bringing
us some support
that we could continue our work.
So there was no
actual profit margin
that we trying to
pay attention to.
We were just hoping the
numbers would all add up.
The other thing is that
we were able to accomplish
a lot with just a few people,
thanks to the internet.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah, say more
about that, because that's
definitely something that--
you were talking about
sort of the older approach
or the traditional approach
of the in-person trainings
and then leveraging technology.
So can you share more
about what that looks like?
THOM BOND: Well the
idea was keep it high
touch even though it's
somewhat high tech.
And so I think where we really
started to see it was important
was in the forum.
And the other thing that we
did was we conference calls
in the beginning, once a month.
And then last year we
decided to switch over.
And we're always
trying to think, OK,
how can we make this better?
How can we make this better?
And so last year
we decided we were
going to move into video,
not just a phone conference
but to move to a video
format, and phone.
We did both.
I think what was important
about this for me was the reach,
and the scalability slash reach.
It didn't matter
if I was sending--
whether it said 550
on there or 5,000.
I mean, it was just you push
the button and away it went.
And so it was like we
got the printing press.
And so we have our
own printing press.
And it could go anywhere.
And the idea behind the
scale of the pricing
was, there are so many
places on this planet--
I mean, to be in the
1% on the planet you
need to earn $30,000 a year.
So if you start
realizing how finances
or how the economy
runs on a global level,
there is no way you would ever--
it would be unconscionable to
pay for a workshop as opposed
to feeding your children.
So I just wanted to break that.
And so the way it turned
out was the folks who
were paying full price
or even double were
funding all these other folks.
So more than half of the
participants in the course
are on scholarship.
And now that's what starts
bringing us into Africa.
That's what starts bringing us
into India, or just into places
where folks don't have
money to spend on workshops.
That had always just kind of
been an upper class thing.
And so we were able
to make that move
and make it available to
anybody who had a computer.
And also this year we
paid special attention
to having a responsive site.
Because as it turns
out, when we're
going into underdeveloped
or less developed countries,
it's all about the phone.
And so we were
able to really make
it usable this year by phone.
Even our conference
call or the video
call you can still [INAUDIBLE].
EARL J. WAGNER:
And along the way
you've been translating
the material
into different languages.
THOM BOND: Yeah.
Well I think another
really important thing
that we paid attention to was
to make the course good enough
that people would tell
their friends about it.
Because we figured
we're never going
to be able to market this
thing into the world.
It had to market
itself into the world.
And so if our
participants weren't
out there telling
everybody, we would not
be anywhere close
to where we are.
I found out about
it from a friend
is our overwhelming largest
source of registration.
And so that was really
important for us to see,
because that's
super efficient when
it comes to marketing, because
all of our participants
were marketing for us.
EARL J. WAGNER: Getting
the strong word of mouth.
So earlier you mentioned
how to make it high
touch while still being high
tech, which [? it ?] eventually
is.
Can you speak more like--
because one of the challenges,
the theme of this discussion
is teaching compassion at scale.
And so much of it is--
well, so I'm curious, what
are the ways that you're
seeing that people are
not just kind of learning
it but actually experiencing and
having a transformative change?
THOM BOND: I would
say every two days
I get an email or a
phone call or something
from somebody saying, thank
you for changing my life.
So the feedback was just coming.
So we knew it was working.
And the other feedback is,
if people tell their friends
about it, then you know it
had to have an effect on them,
otherwise they wouldn't do that.
And so that was
really important to us
to see that we were making it so
that the course was enjoyable,
that it has enough impact that
it would spread itself, really.
We don't have the resources
to market to the entire world.
We need the world to help us.
And that's exactly
what's happening.
And in terms of
other languages, what
was another great
piece of feedback
is that people would start
calling up and saying,
can we translate
your course please?
And so we've accomplished
that in German and Arabic
and in Spanish
now for this year.
We're going to be offering
Spanish-- oh yeah, and English.
And we have projects
now where we have folks
that-- we have a Russian project
right now and a Finnish project
right now.
And there's a French project
that's half done right now.
EARL J. WAGNER:
So it also sounds
a lot like the open source world
where software is developed
in a collaborative
way internationally
through the internet.
The question that I want
to come back to you then
is, if people are
volunteering, helping
with doing the
translation, supporting
the class in these
ways, how do you
ensure that there's the quality
that you're looking for?
How do you ensure integrity?
THOM BOND: That's
funny, that was
about the next thing I
was going to talk about,
which is relationships.
And particularly
the work that we do
is we play with
words a lot as a way
of developing a consciousness.
We use the word needs or
we use the word feelings.
And we define them and then
pursue that understanding.
So it's really important
to find somebody
who understands not
just the other language,
but also understands the work.
Which is why, for example, it
was four years in the making
before the German course, and
likewise for the Arabic course.
So what I'm looking for
is not just somebody
to translate but somebody
who understands the work.
And I develop those people.
When they come to me, I
will help develop them.
We haven't actually
recruited at all.
And the idea behind that was,
when somebody comes to us,
we know they are premotivated.
And the group that I work
with is completely motivated.
There's no having to
push, pull, or anything.
And so we would work
together for years
before I was ready to
let it out of the oven,
because you need to really know
your stuff in order to teach
this at a very beginning level.
EARL J. WAGNER: That sounds
kind of counterintuitive.
Can share more?
THOM BOND: Well I
mean, think about it.
When you introduce
something, everything
is open for question.
And I love it when people
try to kick the tires.
But you never know what
that's going to look like.
So you have to
have every answer.
And the way you have
every answer in this work
is by really
understanding the concept.
So you don't have to know
what they're going to ask you.
You just have to understand
the concepts deeply enough
so that when that question
comes, you apply that,
and then you come
up with the answer.
So it was that
level that we needed
to get to in order for this
to really be successful.
And so we're very carefully
developing at least one person.
The other thing is when
you do translations,
it's important to have readers
who don't really know the work.
So in each language
we also had readers
who would be like a test case.
EARL J. WAGNER: Sure,
it is understandable.
THOM BOND: Right, for a
civilian, not just for somebody
who really practices this work.
EARL J. WAGNER: So you mentioned
the course starting off,
I think, around 2010,
2011, with around 500,
and then actually increasing
about a thousand per year,
increasing to the point where
so far over 12,000 people have--
THOM BOND: Taken the course.
EARL J. WAGNER: --have
taken the course.
And then it's growing each year.
THOM BOND: Yes.
And at this rate--
well, we're going into our
seventh year right now.
And it looks like our
growth rate is increasing.
So that's kind of exciting.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah,
the kind of word of mouth
continues to accelerate.
THOM BOND: And I
also believe, just
in the spiral dynamics
of life, that the planet
is more open to this right now
than it was seven years ago.
So there's a couple
of things going on.
I think there's like a
spiritual, cultural shift
happening on the
planet which has
people leaning towards this.
The other thing is that
we've developed now--
you know, originally we were
just our own kind of-- we
didn't work with anybody else.
But over the years we've
developed partners.
So we work with
Charter for Compassion
or we work with TNVC, which
is an international NVC
organization.
So I suspect what's happening
is as this work becomes more
acceptable in common
culture, we're
going to have more and more
organizations that already
exist in common culture shifting
into being ready for this.
So one of those areas
is clergy for example.
We have a lot of success
because every religion around
has a compassionate
component to it.
In Arabic, it's
called [ARABIC], which
is one of the names of God,
which is the compassionate god.
In Germany it's [GERMAN].
So yeah, we pay attention
to that as well.
EARL J. WAGNER: I also
do want to open it up
for questions from the
audience based on-- let's see,
so we had a chance to talk about
your experience, how you first
learned about this,
your experience
with building NYCNVC, more
recently the Compassion Course
Online.
One thing I'm curious about is,
what do you envision for this?
You mentioned a little bit about
this change for the future.
So we're also
interested in hearing
where you envision this going.
So maybe we want to hear
that, and then we'll
go to questions
from the audience.
THOM BOND: I'm a
very patient man.
And I think that's
probably important for me
because a lot of folks
when they find out
about something like this,
say, wow, this is great.
Let's do it in all the
schools and let's bring it out
to all the corporations.
And the thing is when you look
at it, at least the way I'm
approaching this is that
this particular shift
in consciousness is
an individual affair.
And so the idea of going
out and saying, well, we're
going to teach our whole school
to change its consciousness
is tricky business.
And so the way I look
at this is it's like,
I just want to change one person
5,000 times, 10,000 times.
And so that's the
approach we're taking.
And that's very different than
doing an institutional approach
or an organizational approach.
It's really just an
individual approach.
And so my thinking is, my hope
is that one day somebody says,
oh well, so-and-so,
wouldn't it be great
if the president of the
United States has this?
And I suspect one day the
president of the United States
will have this.
But it's not going to be
because they took it in a course
at the White House.
It's because they learned
it when they were children.
EARL J. WAGNER:
Interesting, just
that it becomes this kind
of lifelong kind of learning
and application.
THOM BOND: It's a massive shift.
I mean, it's a huge shift in
how it is we are doing business
as a human being.
I mean, for thousands
and thousands
of years we've been operating
on who's right, who's wrong.
And what we're
asking people to do
is understand that who's
right and who's wrong
was useful and
has a certain use,
but it's not the end all be all.
The end all be all is, how
can we make things better?
That's kind of how I look at it.
And so yeah, sometimes
who's right and wrong
is important in how to
make something better--
but not that much.
And so what kind of
seems to have happened
is that who's right
and who's wrong
is more important than
making things better.
And what NVC does, what
nonviolent communication does
is it helps to understand
that who's right
and who's wrong only
matters to the extent
that we want to
make things better.
And so the idea
behind using the words
and using the consciousness
is to help bring us
to kind of that mindset.
EARL J. WAGNER: Why
isn't it something
that somebody could just
take a class or in a day?
You mentioned kind of
institutional approach, which
the way that a lot of learning
or teaching is done, maybe
like a day long or
like a week long.
But you don't see that
that's something that--
or can you share more?
THOM BOND: Yeah.
It's not information.
This isn't just information.
This is a way to
reorganize how you
use your mind, and
your body really,
for that matter, the
whole human package.
So that takes time.
In fact, you know,
we had a saying,
we treat nonviolent
communication
like brain surgery,
that serious.
It's like, we really want
to be that good at it.
It's that important.
So that means it takes time.
And I think one of the
things that could really
be harmful in terms
of the spread of this
is to have somebody get
the impression that this
could be learned in a
weekend or in a week.
You can learn about it,
but it's very difficult
to integrate in a week or so.
You can know that
it's ahead of you.
You can see what is to be done.
Although in terms of the
actual integration of it,
our poor little brains
really have a hard time.
Because like I said, it's
such a shift in perspective
that our brains are like,
what are you talking about?
Our brains want to go to
who's right and who's wrong.
And I talk about our brain
being EPRAM, Electronically
Programmable Random Access
Memory, which it kind of is.
And so a lot of our brains
have a program of who's right
and who's wrong
burned into them.
And so what this is
is it's a new program.
So the only way we're
going to reprogram
is by repeatedly burning
in the new paradigm.
And that just simply
takes time, because we
have hundreds of
thousands if not millions
of these neural pathways
set up for right or wrong.
And so now what I'm
asking you to do
is set up a neural pathway for,
how can I make things better?
EARL J. WAGNER: And then
kind of shifting from--
like actually maybe learning
new habits or new ways of being.
THOM BOND: Yeah.
And that's why, right, it
takes just years often,
because it is just simply
having enough rehearsal
to be able to overcome what
I call the habitual mind.
EARL J. WAGNER: So
also coming back
to the theme around teaching
compassion at scale,
I'm curious if you have for
somebody else engaging in--
also kind of sharing these
teachings or another approach
in this space, any kind
of insights or wisdom
that you've developed,
lessons learned maybe,
or best practices in the time
that you've been doing this?
THOM BOND: Make sure
it has an impact.
And that was where we
just kept going back
to make sure we had a
product that had an impact.
And as long as you have that,
it kind of goes downhill.
It's easy from there.
It's no longer a struggle.
It's just a matter of
keeping up with the growth.
But that means that
you really have
to do a great job
in the beginning.
You have to go to
the drawing board
and you have to make sure you
have an amazing product that's
going to have an
impact on people,
and then the rest just happens.
It's kind of like the lazy
way to do it in a way.
EARL J. WAGNER:
Just starting off
with something that has impact,
that works, and then building.
THOM BOND: Right.
So it manages--
it markets itself.
So that was one of the thing.
And every year we work on making
the course a little better.
EARL J. WAGNER:
It's continuously
iterating and improvement.
THOM BOND: And that could be
a technological improvement
like this year when we went
to video and cell phones.
Or it could be an
editing improvement
in the actual
content of the course
to make it just a little
crisper or a little more
understandable.
EARL J. WAGNER: Yeah, so
we're coming to the end.
Let's actually check the time.
So we have a few minutes
left, but we do want open it
up for questions from the
audience about anything
that we've covered so far.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARL J. WAGNER: So I'll go
ahead and repeat the question
for the recording, that for
somebody who's just learning
this, it seems so simple.
But then actually putting it
into practice can be hard.
And when can you actually--
you can be kind of awkward.
And when can you actually see--
when do you see that
shift happening?
THOM BOND: So it is
simple and hard, right?
I liken it to picking
up a 500 pound barbell.
Really simple action, right?
You bend down, you
pick it up, no biggie.
That said, it's hard.
And so I really do see
nonviolent communication
that way.
So why is it hard?
And it goes back to what
we were just talking about,
right, the habitual mind.
It's already got a program in
there like, leave me alone.
I've got this.
It's working just fine.
Leave me alone.
And so when we start to
get to the other shore
is when we hang in
there long enough
to get an experience,
like I had with my father.
And it was like,
this stuff works.
And so there's this period
before we get there,
before we can pick
that thing up,
where it seems
relatively frustrating,
which is why community is such
an important aspect of what
we do.
Because I want you to understand
that this is for real.
And that's the other reason
we tell stories in the course.
Because even when I read
the course I'm like,
that concept seems
kind of strange.
I don't quite get it.
And I'm writing it.
But then when you
read the story,
you're like, oh,
that's how that works.
And so what happens is one day
you're going to have a story.
Something's going to happen.
And you're going to
go, oh, it works.
And then you're naturally going
to be attracted to doing it.
So it's getting past
that place where
it doesn't work until we get to
the place where it does work.
And again, I think
it's so important.
I'm just such a big
fan of this work.
And I knew Marshall
when he was alive
and I made a personal
commitment to him
that I would carry the torch.
And so I'm really
passionate about this.
And so my job is to
carry you to that place
where you get that
aha experience, right?
And then you're going to be
self-motivated from there.
The thing is that's
a pretty big period.
And so I really want to
focus on staying with you.
Because I know for
this work, for example,
if you don't get
through that stage,
I'm imagining you could think
this very easily yourself.
This doesn't work.
You could go, oh,
this doesn't work.
This hammer doesn't work.
It was because I just didn't
figure out how to use it yet.
And so that's my goal,
is to allow you--
or to support you to get
through that beginning period
where it almost feels like
that formulation period
where we're putting 10 in
and we're getting one out.
It's that day when you
put one in and get one out
that you're hooked, where
you go oh, OK, it worked.
And so that's what my
life's all about actually
is getting you to that place.
I didn't realize that
in the beginning.
I thought, oh, we'll
just teach this stuff
and everybody will get it.
But the problem is
there's community
for the right-wrong thinking.
There's plenty of
community for judgment.
So we needed to have
another community to help us
as social creatures
be ourselves.
EARL J. WAGNER: What do you
see as the differences in terms
of supporting and
fostering community
for this kind of
work, like in person,
locally within the New
York versus internationally
and across different
languages and cultures?
THOM BOND: Well, the
way we're doing it,
I mean, we're doing it online.
We have a regular old
fashioned forum, message forum.
And then we also have a
number of Facebook page
where people can go and connect.
And often in the
course that's part
of it is when you do an
exercise and then you
go share your results.
The other part is
the conference calls.
That's a really big piece.
EARL J. WAGNER: So
just for both of those,
you mentioned doing an exercise
and sharing their results.
So tell us about
the impact of that.
Why that in particular?
THOM BOND: Well
it's so important
to understand that
somebody could have--
you know, how did
you make this work?
What did you do?
What was the result
that you had?
And then that helps
pave the way for others.
So the more folks
we have in the mix,
the more
cross-pollination we get,
and the more inspiration
we get, and therefore
the more results we get.
EARL J. WAGNER: Wow, yeah.
So actually kind of people
sharing their own experiences
like you had with your
father, sharing the stories
that they're
noticing, the shifts
in perspective with
their experience
and creating kind
of more momentum.
Great.
Another question?
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
[INAUDIBLE]
EARL J. WAGNER: Yes,
I'll repeat the question.
When you're learning
this, how can you
be putting this into practice
in a world where you were saying
before, like the
right-wrong thinking,
people are talking to you
using the right-wrong violent
versus the nonviolent approach.
THOM BOND: Well
so the first part
is to have it living inside me.
And then I have the opportunity
once I have that awareness
and once I have what I
call needs awareness,
then I can share that
perspective with someone.
I can share my
consciousness with them.
For example, my father--
if I said, well what are
you needing right now,
he would say, I need you
to get your act together.
But instead, I put it in a
way that he could connect to.
And so that's one of the
things we can do as we express.
In terms of when
somebody is kind
of heaving some judgment in
our way, in our direction,
the other practice
is internal, which
is to empathize first
with ourselves as
to how I'm really not
doing this and what
I would like to be achieving.
And then once I have that
self-empathy part done--
which I did with
my father, right?
I was like, what do
I want right now?
I want to connect with this guy.
So when we get to
that place when
we're what we call
self-empathized
and we're grounded
in our needs, then I
can start to listen to other
people who are in judgement.
Now the basic
operating principle
of nonviolent
communication is everything
we do we do to meet a need,
including judging people.
And so if somebody
is judging me,
if I want to go into
the old paradigm,
I'd be like that's wrong,
and I could judge the judger.
But in the new paradigm
what I do is I say wow,
they must be in pain.
There's some unmet need
that they have that
has them speaking this way.
And so for example, if
you said Thom, you know,
you're just such a loud mouth.
I can't stand it anymore.
Instead of going no I'm not,
instead I could [? wonder, ?]
well what is it
that you're needing?
And so I can address
that or I could even
ask you about it and say, well,
would it be better for you
if we had more mutuality or
more partnership right now?
Would that help?
And so what I do is
I kind of suss out
what the need beneath
the judgement is.
And that helps me connect to
people who are using judgement.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
THOM BOND: Yes.
EARL J. WAGNER:
Yeah, making guesses
but can't figure out what
the person is needing.
THOM BOND: Well, that's
where the practice comes in.
I call it the parallel
universe of needs.
It's running the show right now.
Everything that's happening
in this room, everything
that's happening on this
campus is the result of needs.
And look, I'm not saying
that's actually the truth.
But when I act like
that's the truth,
that's the important
part for me.
I was a philosophy major.
I spent a lot of
money to find out
that I don't know
what the truth is.
But what I do know is
when I act like this
is the truth, when I
see the world this way,
that it changes my experience.
So the trick for me is
to just learn to see.
And this is the very
first part of this.
First we need to see
that parallel universe.
And that's part of the work
that we do in the workshops
and in the course is
to really point out
how that is really there.
Just like with my father, right?
He was being motivated
by his love for me.
And so that's what
we want to first see.
So then the next
part is, we want
to learn to articulate that
so that we can share it
with those around us.
The next part is,
this is where we
bump into our habitual
mind, where we're just not
accustomed to thinking this way.
And so another part
of it is, how do we
make that journey from the old
paradigm to the new paradigm.
In other words if we say,
well that's the old paradigm,
trash it, and just start
the new one, it won't work.
And in fact, a lot of
work around compassion
is just basically people saying,
look, just be compassionate.
You know, it's the
right thing to do.
And what I'm trying to do is
say, here is how you can do it.
We can break it down into steps
so that you can achieve it.
So that's really what I want
to bring, that understanding.
That allows me to work--
well, eventually it will help me
work with other people, right?
But the homework
for me is to learn
to see the parallel
universe first.
And it's weird.
It's like we're not
accustomed to that.
So it does take
practice and rehearsal.
And it's so much fun for me,
like in a workshop, to say,
do you see it yet?
And they're like,
well, not really.
Do you see it now?
And there are different
exercises that we do.
Like I would tell
you, for example,
I'll say, well OK, what do I do
to meet my need for communion?
And so I'll say, so I go
for a walk in the woods.
Now you have to guess my needs.
This is like an
exercise that we do.
And so what happens is
eventually with guessing right,
with enough hit and miss,
you'll develop that vision
of the parallel universe.
So that's the short
answer to your question
is that you just develop it.
It's actually just a skill.
EARL J. WAGNER: Other questions?
Yeah, in the back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EARL J. WAGNER: Great.
Practicing snapping
out of the judgements.
THOM BOND: I don't snap.
But what I do is transform.
So the first part
is to get curious,
and to get curious about what?
Well first we have
to understand that--
and it's kind of an intellectual
understanding at first,
that if I'm in judgment,
that I have an unmet need,
and that I'm using my judgment
as a way to respond to it.
And so what we do is learn
to translate judgments.
In other words, we're
not saying stop judging
and start doing this.
We're saying, when
we're judging,
let's take a look
at that judgment
and see what the need is there.
So for example, everything we do
we do to [INAUDIBLE], including
judgment.
But imagine if I said to
everybody in this room,
said, so how many folks
here would like to talk
about how stupid you are--
nobody.
But if I said how many
folks in this room
would be interested in talking
about how we could have
more flow and connection
and understanding,
anybody interested in
that conversation--
just about everybody.
I see a lot of heads
going like this.
And so that is the difference.
We start out, the
needs beneath stupid
are flow, connection,
and understanding.
So what this work does is
when I'm in that judgement
I go oh, here's a great
opportunity for me to figure
out what my needs are.
And so we learn to translate
those judgments into the needs.
And again, that's a
practice that we do.
It's a skill that we develop.
And so we're not
saying don't judge.
We're saying translate
judgment, because judgments
are trying to do something.
It's just that they're doing
it in a way that disconnects.
And so when we can look at
that judgment, figure out,
well, what's the
yummy part of that,
then we can just focus on that.
EARL J. WAGNER: I
want to follow up
on that, because
you mentioned it
can be this long term
learning process.
You mentioned how
you're shifting
these judgments
around your father
early on, that there were
other times along the way.
I'm curious for you
most recently-- it's
maybe kind of a
personal question--
but what are some of the
most more recent kind of ahas
that you've had for
shifting out a judgment
that you've experienced?
THOM BOND: I'm
constantly empathizing
with terrorists it seems.
EARL J. WAGNER:
Pretty heavy, yeah.
THOM BOND: I'm constantly asking
myself, why would you do that?
And I even remember back
around 9/11, I was like--
I for one don't believe
that there are evil people.
I think that there are
things that don't work
and people who are in a whole
lot of pain who do things
that are really destructive.
And so whenever I
see something that's
really destructive, at
this point my interest is,
what kind of pain are they in?
Probably the one that was one
of the hardest ones for me
was there a series
of knockout attacks.
They're called knockout attacks
where somebody will just
pick a total stranger
and hit them so hard
that they knock them out
and they fall to the ground.
And I remember when I first
heard about that I was like,
we've got to round all these
people up and put him in jail.
And then I was like, wait
a minute, wait a minute.
What is that?
And then I was to
able to just go, why?
Why would I ever do that?
What level of pain
would I have to be in,
and what would that pain be
about to have that happen?
And so instead of thinking
about how wrong they are,
I was thinking, well what
if you had a life where
you had absolutely
no empowerment
whatsoever, no choice,
no power in your life?
And it's something that we
all so desperately desire.
Imagine 16 years of
that, 17 years of that.
And so now a knockout attack
doesn't look like somebody
doing something evil to me.
It looks like somebody who's
in a tremendous amount of pain
acting that out.
Which doesn't mean that I
believe in knockout attacks,
although it does give
me a way to relate
to somebody who did something
that I absolutely abhor.
And I think that's the real
important part of this.
And that is that
this work allows
us to connect to people who have
done things that we absolutely
can't stand.
And if we can't do that, how
are we ever going to get back
on track as a globe?
Because somebody is
always doing something.
I'm doing things
that I don't like.
So somebody is always doing
something I don't like.
So if that's going
to stop us from being
able to relate to one another,
I think we're in trouble.
So this work allows us
to make a connection,
even though somebody's doing
something we don't like,
or even something we abhor.
EARL J. WAGNER: I mean,
one of the real challenges
like in political
discussion, somebody
might say-- people
will often say,
well, you know, this person
who's doing knockout attacks,
terrorists, they don't
deserve to be related to.
They don't deserve empathy.
How do you respond to that?
THOM BOND: Wow, I don't
think I've heard that yet.
Although if somebody
said that, I
would empathize with them,
the person who is saying that.
Because in order for
them to say that,
they've got their
own package of pain
that they're carrying around.
So I wouldn't argue with that.
I would empathize with that.
EARL J. WAGNER: Making
guesses about what
they might be needing.
THOM BOND: Right, and valuing.
EARL J. WAGNER: Thanks.
Other questions?
I think so we're looking at--
I think we're right up against--
actually, yeah, we're
right up on the hour.
So I want to thank you.
So just to provide
some more information,
I've been Earl J.
Wagner presenting--
actually interviewing here
Thom Bond from NYCNVC.
If you want to find out more
about the Compassion Course
Online, they can go to
compassionatecourse.org.
THOM BOND: Correct.
EARL J. WAGNER: And remind us
when that's starting for 2017.
THOM BOND: June 21, right,
first day of-- yeah,
I think it's the first
day of summer, or winter.
EARL J. WAGNER: Great.
And so for folks here
within the Google community,
if you're wanting to
participate in a local group,
you can go to go
compassion-course, compassion
dash course.
And Thom, I want to
thank you for joining us
for the discussion.
[APPLAUSE]